so now I base people's guts on their
track record so if this person has
trusted a gut trust their God trust
their gut then I will tell this person
you know what I need to trust your gut
oh because they have a good gut some
someone's like trust or God trust her
God
[Music]
welcome back to another very serious
episode of careful boys we have geo with
us today wow lucky for us
um traditional what a pickup
take a second and think about this all
right what is the worst advice you ever
gave somebody oh did I ever gave someone
like something that you try to help with
and you said the wrong thing and they
did what you said and you went just be
yourself
just be you how did that backfire no I
don't know you know what
um I don't I don't know the instance uh
but
um now
I don't say this anymore
so before I used to go like when people
oh should I do I'm like whatever
whatever I'm stuck between this yeah
ruin this whatever and I'll be like I
would just trust your gut that's what I
would used to say oh but now I realize
some people got stupid guys
so now I
on their track record so if this person
has trusted a gut trust their God trust
their gut then I will tell this person
you know what I need to trust your gut
oh because they have a good gut some
someone's like trust their God trust her
God
I go what does your gut say and they're
like this I go dude that other one other
thing why don't you just take out why
don't you just take out the middle man
and be like trust your track record
do you make the best decision when it
comes to dating partners no then don't
[__] trust your God this new guy
you're talking about I wouldn't don't
hate him yeah cause before you you just
blindly believe it right and you're like
okay cool because I think when people
are giving advice they're they're also
going this works for me right should
work for you and then you start to
realize like not everyone's the same or
in different places some people might be
smarter than you or dumber than you at
certain things and then I was like oh
actually this blanket this whole blanket
rule thing is not a great idea I stopped
giving advice for that reason why what
did you do because what's in your head
they can't execute it so like if you is
there a situation that you did a thing
no it's like repeated like so you know
like
as you grow you start changing your
beliefs right about the world so like
for example if you're smart
was
um
resources to get to where they want to
be right so all they so maybe some
people don't have access to it so then
if you have a friend that's like man all
I wanted to do was [__] be a gymnast
or whatever and you're like well guess
what I know a buddy with a gymnastics
gym that'll probably let you train for
free this and that and just set them all
up for [__] success and then the one
thing that's missing is
self-determination or something there's
other things that can't get them there
even though you give them all this [__]
to [__] succeed and then that's when
I realized oh [__] I was so wrong like
there's so much independent motivation
needed in order for someone to actually
get to where they want to be and all
that and I'm all like everyone just
gotta [__] do their own [__] and stop
bothering me and asking me questions
that's kind of true though no but that's
also a thing too where it's like you you
you always want to pass on what you
wished you had so for you you probably
had a determination you're like I just
don't have the resources I know what you
need but then this person's lacking like
12 other things too yeah like [__]
because I thought that that was the
route that worked out for me yeah yeah
so then I think oh that's what yeah but
maybe they needed motivation or
something else yeah one of the uh worst
advice I gave was uh so like
I took note of things that were
happening in my life because I when I
did so you think you could dance season
one I remembered that everybody in our
cast of top 16 finalists had almost
everybody had like a significant other
going into it oh wow the stress of doing
the show was so high and and the time
commitments and everything that uh every
almost everybody broke up with whoever
they were with because it was so hard
you know like things were just crazy I
mean how come they're not being
supportive and all the other contestants
were so fine I think it was
a different time where like you know
dancers on a TV show like that was very
new that was like the first one of that
nature where like you were sequestered
it was like a reality show type thing so
it was different
and so season when season three came
around
uh and this is like so I've I messed up
because I said this is D-Trix and he
still blames me for this uh we were he
got on as you should yeah as he should
his he he's on the show he makes it as a
finalist we're at like one of the first
dinners uh I'm with him and he's like
talk to me about advice on the show and
stuff and I was like dude just let you
know man everybody that was on the show
with a girlfriend
didn't work out everybody broke up
and he goes oh okay all right he goes
and breaks up with his girl oh that is
not your fault that's not advice you're
giving him data from your experience
they had like no problems and he goes
yeah Ryan told me that uh you know it's
uh thanks for getting my back dude yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah you didn't do
anything wrong he broke up with her and
then he hit me up like right after he's
all hey I did what you said you know I
broke up with her and I was like
no way I didn't think he was gonna break
I was just telling him like yo you know
it's probably better that like if you go
in single you can focus on this oh so
you did so you did kind of I said that I
didn't think he would do it I just I
would just say like you're his friend if
you tell me right now hey drop bar I'd
be like oh [__] he's my friend he wants
my best interest in mine
no but for sure yeah so he like for sure
like at like right it is your fault
pre-season really good like I mean he
was the top 20 I just started like
I love how they're in a perfect
relationship like gotta shake this [__]
off of me this dead weight to this day I
can't dance with all this anchor he
still tells the story like when he goes
down his relationships he still tells
Yeah I broke up with her because Ryan
told me it was better but he seems like
he's in such a happy relationship yeah
he's good does that ex-girlfriend know
this story I I you know what's crazy I
feel like he broke up with her and told
her like what I said oh my God I'm not
sure I don't know if that's true I don't
know if he's just like trying to like
stab me further but like when he says it
I think I think he told her that I gave
him that advice or is he trying to
protect himself maybe I don't know
that's another thing too is like
you can give advice
and they might twist what was said and
they might make a different action out
of it and go you told me to [__] do
this I mean he directly did the thing I
said specifically I mean in your case
you're wrong assistance in your case
you're wrong but there's there's so many
things like that that do go down though
that's what I realized too people got
their own algorithms you say something
right and then if they got a stupid ass
like I'll go in like uh you know Alex
ramosi he's like this guy is crushing
with like business advice everything he
he gives is [__] bars I go in the
comments thinking everyone's like oh
thank you for helping me with my life
whatever there's people that are [__]
arguing yeah criticizing it yeah and
they're like bro do you have nine
figures yeah this guy's giving you free
advice but your own stupid ass algorithm
can't see the true content no because
he's from his mom's basement going like
dude as a business as an economics major
you don't know [__] bro yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's why it's tough because
like that context is everything like I
even with my journey on the same thing
that Joe said when I got older I was
like I stopped saying advice to people
because people like oh I want some
advice to be like I'm not going to give
you advice I'll give you my opinion and
I was like okay cool that's my safe way
of protecting myself so I don't put
somebody in that position but then you
still got [__] that you don't know right
so like for example we was obviously in
crypto last year right and [__] like
Luna rest in peace she was killing it
right so obviously it's just killing it
people just like yo you in crypto so I
remember my cousin was like yeah what
are you doing what are you doing I was
like Yo dude I mean this thing called
Luna we've [__] kind of ripping it
right but that's the hard thing it was
something like crypto it's like you
could be like like dude this crypto is
Bomb but if somebody doesn't do
something and they buy it like at the
top you know what I mean at the time you
told them they waited a month or
something yeah but like that that [__]
sticks to you it like it makes you feel
really really bad right so it wasn't
just like him it was like next thing you
know a week later he's like Yo dude I
told my buddy he just put in 10 grand
and I'm sitting there and I'm like uh
and then literally everything starts to
[__] crash and stuff like that you
know what I mean that now you're just
sitting in a pool of like
this kind of guilt where you're like oh
if I would have just not told anyone
that's why I told people don't tell
anybody you know what I'm saying like
you guys want to help all your friends
because you told people not to tell
anybody because well but yeah all the
time when people go up it's all good but
when things go down you know what I mean
you're like man I I really hope that you
know it's not my fault but you you're
gonna get that guilt no matter what so
that's that's why advice or whatever
it's so complex but and it's also just
dangerous the older you get you just
want to just hold on to your own [__]
you know you never gave you guys never
gave blatantly wrong advice that you
regret like in your earlier years of not
being careful I'm pretty sure all of us
has but we don't remember yeah because
you're constantly changing your things
of what you believe is right so in the
moment when you believe something is
right and someone asks you that you
genuinely want to help you go oh I got
this [__] new thing man that I want
to tell you about because I just found
out and then you just go yeah yeah and
then you forget everyone goes on with
their days they forget that they grow
grow they don't think that the way that
they used to and then you probably
affected so many people around you with
bad advice well that's like every time
we were SDA and trying to power witness
to people our witness yeah that was bad
advice right that's true telling other
religions that they were doing it wrong
yeah yeah that's a hundred percent true
and then we all no one has I don't think
people remember their
uh faults much or what they've done
wrong or who they used to be yeah I
think that's we're not capable of doing
that because you can't grow and progress
if you hold on to your old beliefs of
who that's that's the crazy thing is I
don't even think I would have remembered
saying that to Dietrich unless he told
me and then and because like sometimes
you don't even know you're giving advice
well it's not even like I was just
talking because it's not a fault unless
someone tells you it's a fault or unless
like you see it happening almost like no
one tells you yeah right you don't know
and then you don't see the effects of
like the other way too right sometimes
somebody be coming up to you and be like
yo I'm glad you told me this because I
did this invala and things worked out
and you're like I said that yeah yeah
yeah true true yeah yeah yeah yeah you
just like Ryan said sometimes you think
you're just having conversation you're
not necessarily trying to like [__]
see into the future for somebody's
[__] soul you know what I mean and
making judgment calls and stuff like
you're really just talking about stuff
from your perspective but once you said
that to dietrichs like your intention
wasn't to be like oh you should break up
with her
I mean it wouldn't have mattered to me
whether he did or not I was just like
saying I was just it's like saying it's
like the same outcome but like saying a
difference is it's different from being
like I think you should break up with
her but it's like yo everybody did
really well when they like was single
and focused yeah and it is true but
say certain things you once it leaves
your mouth it's out of your response
like it's not your responsibility
algorithm yeah like they perceive it a
completely different way based on their
own experiences so it's like once it
leaves your mouth it's not like one of
the most beautiful fall one of the most
beautiful things we witnessed here was
uh men from what's a mortgage remember
like when he went bankrupt like yeah the
second time and you could bring the
[__] data and go like hey you know
usually you're more successful if you're
more single focused on your own [__]
yeah they have their own talk the the
wife is like you know what like the only
the only way to get out of this hole is
if you don't have husband and you don't
have wife duties I'm gonna take our son
we're gonna go we're gonna go I'm gonna
take care of him you spend 24 hours a
[__] day for however long you need to
get out of this hole and then so that
could that could have been the other
D-Trix conversation hey like I this is
what this is the day that I got maybe
for this season
um what like I'll talk to you when I can
but I'm really gonna try to smash this
[__] show and then they could have
came out way stronger had he had that
algorithm you know yeah but everyone
processed things at the [__] just giving
advice right now by the way no no never
never never trust your God everybody
especially
like crazy your gut's gonna take you in
the right direction
you're [__] like crazy it relieves
people of personal responsibility when
you have someone that gives you like a
road map and then you take it and you go
I followed your road map and it failed
you son of a [__] and it's like they
never have to take a uh responsibility
for those actions because they took
someone else's advice oh yeah it's true
yeah Ryan told me to do it or whatever
you know it's like whatever happened to
you with something when people came back
and was like yo you told me this and
you're like I did
Joe I thought you were talking to him
well this is why I don't talk too much
about investment advice and things like
that because I did I did want to share
financial advisor I did want to share
with like hey I'm doing this I'm doing
that like I'm into this like I I do talk
about the coins that I was into and
whatever and then like I'm like hey I
think this is a good buy for whatever
reasons but I never say the words you
should buy it too because every single
person has different levels of what they
can stomach their risk tolerance what
their situation is like if you're making
like you know two grand a month is it
wise to put two grand a month into
crypto probably not but if you're making
oh [__] but if you're making a hundred
grand a month and you can stomach
throwing away two grand a month on
crypto maybe that's okay with you right
so like two grand so it's like it's
ratio it's depending it's every person
has the has this like ability to either
do or not do and I have to assess that
first from every person and for
everything being like relationships and
whatever if they're asking me a genuine
question that they want me to answer
like truthfully then I I think what I
try to do now is to see if like what
stage they are in and what would be
appropriate for them instead of me going
like this is what will work for me and
it should probably work for you yeah
there's still only one piece of advice
that I still kind of sometimes give to
my homies and stuff like that anytime
one of my homies is like you know oh I'm
dating somebody new I'm the issue a
Vietnamese girl
and then they're like yes I'm gonna and
then I'm just like be careful
because that's even what Clinton Jackson
says
Quinn Jackson says he loves Asian chicks
but he stays away from the Vietnamese
ones I just said be careful it doesn't
that's done yeah it's very neutral huh
this is my opinion I don't know you
don't go be careful I go check the track
record man
shake the gut health you know on the
other side
um there I have been blamed for not
following advice
which is pretty crazy what advice like
some of my homies got mad at me so I
think like for uh for me like the way
that I like to like
um formulate like my ideas I'll have
like a notion of something and then I'll
ask different people that I think have
different perspectives on it so that I
can get the most well-rounded oh okay
right like so when I first got into like
the best game or whatever I'm like okay
Steve what do you think then he's like
super into crypto I'll ask people super
into real estate people are super into
stocks conservative risk like everything
right now I go all the way around and
then I go
okay cool and then of course when when
you're speaking to every single one none
of those people think you're talking to
90 other people so they just tell you
and then they might think you're an
[__] like wait I literally told you
oh right right right you're not doing
that exact thing but then I'm talking to
90 other people to formulate what I
think is the best yeah and uh I'm
talking about Steve right no no this is
Early College in Early College I would
have friends that would be like and it
ended up being like a consensus in the
group Bart never listens to us but then
I'm like no no you guys don't understand
I'm not an [__] because I don't keep
coming back with the same problem
because that's what [__] is right
like give me advice you give me advice
they just want to vent I I am evolving
but I'm not evolving in the way you're
telling me it's I get everything one
person and then I go oh okay I think
okay I think this way fits me but then
so I'm still I'm not staying in the same
place I'm actually moving but and people
wouldn't get mad at me for not each
following every single one but all I'm
like all of you guys literally are given
contradictory advice though and that's
good yeah that's how like a good idea
forms a good perspective yeah you get a
rough Rock and you're all of us polish
it a different way and I have this new
thing to take on that's true that's
probably the best way to but once you
open up the door with advice right like
depending on who's giving you that
advice they're giving you a piece of
themselves so now they're invested into
your actions that's true because it's
like if you now it's like hey I told you
something now you might validate me
being wrong or right depending on how
you make actions and then it's like oh
then they get insecure of like oh maybe
you think I'm stupid that's why you
didn't follow what I said you know and
so I think it's also dependent on like
can the person giving you this advice
also deal with your actions there's just
so much annoying it is there's so much
[__] people say [__] personal though
yeah it is it's really true that's true
I've been telling this guy that's like
sitting right there gotta move to Vegas
gotta move to Vegas gotta move to Vegas
got him into Vegas
what the [__] you don't care about your
wife you don't care about your family
you don't care about your future I'm
just polishing a rock the right way by
getting a bunch of advice hey that's
good so he's gonna move to the point in
between all the places
here I am in beautiful Marsh all right
Eddie Bauer fifty percent off every day
kid just complex Victorville
that's amazing I heard that there's
really good break dancing schools for
kids in Las Vegas
oh there is yeah District yeah
absolutely all the dishes yeah
absolutely yeah but that don't make
Vegas that tight yeah it does well I'm
just saying if you guys want a job
there's break dancing schools
that are highly recognized I'm moving
that's the biggest because I need work
at a break dancing school moving there
because you need a house
that's good not house lessons house
music
there is a community called Terra Luna
we've seen it there is it's still there
and I was so gonna buy a place there you
[__] troll just to be funny yeah
there's one called Solana too there's a
bunch of that's a bunch of like crypto
named communities I gotta pee we're
gonna cut
[Laughter]
must be bad dude
[Music]
thank you